[Music]
um
so this is where I met Commander X
he was sitting here cowboy hat out
and he was reading he had a thick sci-fi
novel and I just recently had published
my first novel so it seemed appropriate
that I dropped two dollars in there
and he looked up and he had this
interesting face craggy
and a definite story
so the the gut reaction of the novelist
is to is to engage and find out more
but little did I know that I was about
to fall into the quicksand
of hackers of anonymous and the
Beautiful randomness
of life
[Music]
foreign
books
[Music]
I came and brought him a book and he
read it
I wanted [__] stories I didn't
reality has become a bit too much right
then and it was [__] great it's a
great book
I didn't have an idea for six weeks who
this guy was he was just a friend on the
street
but then he told me that he was a cyber
warlord one of the generals in anonymous
online her to identified as being part
of anonymous and other groups have
carried out dozens of high-profile
online operations and that he was on the
run from the FBI and had been for six
years because I felt that the
prosecution was political against myself
I chose to shoot me into Exile and I'm
in Canada now and there was an article
that could corroborate all this and it
was in the New Yorker and I should go
home and and read it I mean he's polite
about it okay okay cool yeah take a look
at it tonight but I knew from the look
in his eyes you know it wasn't buying
that meat without inspecting it I
cross-referenced the name that was in
the article Christopher Mark doyon and
up popped his mug shot from when he was
arrested for trying to sell large
quantities of LSD that's a Grateful Dead
gig in in Indiana
and when his face popped up I got
goosebumps
it was a life-changing moment
I gave the same work every time I reveal
myself that I could count
that he was just like
dude
dude you really are this
person
[Music]
so let's
bring us to today
today
well today they're making a [__]
movie about my life
I've been called type of terrorist but I
have to laugh right now at the [__]
very idea what is an information
terrorist please I mean can somebody
help me with that how can I terrorize
people with with the truth
[Music]
Commander X had a knack for being at the
beginning of these movements being right
there the information activists just
trying to make a world a little better
he's smart he is articulate and his
words have power that most peoples do
not
that's dangerous to the power elite we
fight bad guys and tyrants
wherever we find him he was very
divisive some people loved him some
people hated him he was a distraction at
best I think of times he would type in
all caps you know what I mean like he
was a guy who who commanded attention is
anyone who did the most to take that
edge between absurdity and awe-inspiring
and just [__] Ram it over to the
[__] absurdity part it was commander
rex look this is a war I mean straight
up this is a warp I think there's like
an Entertainer in him I mean he likes to
tell stories he likes to kind of take
you into a whole world and sometimes you
don't know how much of that is
exaggeration you have to put a person
behind the mask people want stories
so commander X did make a good story
[Music]
I was talking with my editor at the New
Yorker
about doing a larger piece about
Anonymous and to me the story was how
has activism
moved from the streets to the internet
and then back to the streets that was I
think fundamentally the story I was
telling and Commander X was it was
really the personification of that it
was a profile of a Contemporary American
activist
he grew up in Maine like on a ranch in
Maine but you know he had a difficult
life he had a difficult upbringing his
father was abusive my parents were not
very good people
I'm just going to end it there but they
were not very good people and so I spent
a lot of time at my grandmother's house
and I had become fascinated with the
idea of computers the Industrial
Revolution expanded the strength of
man's muscles in the reach of his hands
the information revolution is magnifying
the power of his brain changing forever
the way Americans were played traveled
and even think
I was always quite fascinated with the
computer in Star Trek to think [__]
talk so I convinced this guy who worked
for my daddy as a pharmacist assistant
to bring me to the local University and
show me a real [__] computer so he
brought me down to the university sat me
down and of course I immediately sit
there and I was like Hello computer
because the only knowledge I have
computer is Star Trek and it's supposed
to talk right and he's like no no it
doesn't work like that and there was a
program it was a very basic chat program
it has a freaking 13 year old kid you're
sitting there to shoot [__] kind of
start talking back to you you're like
[__] me you know that's that's
incredible you know then I went to my
grandmother and I said I need 100 bucks
there's no way to buy a computer back
then you it was a kit that you bought
and then they sent it to you and you had
to literally solder the [__] thing
together and then plug it into a
television and a cassette recorder and
the cassette recorder acted as the hard
drive and I said Grandma just sit down
please I want to talk to you I am
convinced grandma that these things
called computers are going to change the
world
and she's like well what does it do I
was like you can use it as a calculator
you could balance your checkbook with it
you can play video games
chilling back in the chair and she says
well I'm going to spend two dollars
and buy you a pocket calculator
and then I'm going to sit you down and
teach you how to balance your checkbook
and then if you do all that I'll take
you out to the video game store and for
40 bucks I'll buy you a pawn game
and you can just skip the 100 computer
as a grandma you just don't understand
if this is going to change the world
it took me about a year to put the thing
together
so you can see that coming into it from
that way in that fashion just
the fascination is never going to wear
off now I'm like a kid in the candy
store I'm living my own science fiction
I wake up every morning I get in front
of that computer I I am not unhappy I
spend 10 12 hours a day in front of that
thing and I just find it all fascinating
every single [__] day I get up
[Music]
he gets to Cambridge
he was sleeping on park benches my
understanding of it was just because he
liked the mobility of it he claims that
he was always homeless by choice and
then I went to a Grateful Dead show
inevitably that was going to come into
it and it was in Boston
and I ran across an anti-apartheid
protest
I stopped I hung out with people I
smoked some pot
um I was given flyers and she had you
know you make friends with people that
got a flyer in their hand you're going
to read it I was so angry that there
could be a system of government in our
Century in my lifetime that you had to
go into a police station and put your
hand up to a color shot and based on how
dark or light you were that's how many
rights you got that is [__]
ridiculous and then they're like yeah
well you know thanks for hanging out
with us and you know we're doing this
thing [__] tomorrow they got me
really good with the whole hanging out
with me and smoking some weed thing
because you know being a Solitude kind
of kid anybody that felt made me feel
like I was their pal you know they got
the time of day
and you know of course I had to do other
things I went to a lot of Rock shows
back then I had to make a living and I
did that at Rock shows not only am I not
ashamed but I'm somewhat proud of the
fact that we sold really good LSD
we would go out and do a U.S tour with
the guy and we would raise [__] tons of
money and just dealt more is all it did
I went to more Dead shows I made more
money I went to more protests
some dude with [__] cakey ass dreads
literally down to his knees would cycle
up to me and give me maybe a little
piece of paper folded up like this
in the passing crowd and it would be the
next elf action or the next Alf action
or the next protest against the entire
part-time
that's definitely the whole texture of
the cloth and it just gets woven Tighter
and Tighter as I become more and more
sucked into this idea of just permanent
resistance to all this [__] up [__]
to things like the animal Liberation
Front the Earth Liberation Front I did
my tours of Duty in both of those and
then eventually our little silly little
hacker group that we call the people
celebration front the plf we were more
of like a little militia we adopted
these titles called commander and we
were we'd all dressed in camo when we
went to protest hey one day my friend
sat me down and said uh look we we want
to have a talk about something
a activist group
by the name of anonymous had hacked the
forms of the Epilepsy Foundation of
America
and they had placed on the Forum on the
front page a animated gif these gifts
these animated gifts they stroked very
brightly to stroke very fast
they could take an epileptic and cause
them to have a seizure just from looking
at it four people went to the hospital
across the country
and these people were literally harmed
by hackers thousands of miles away
physically
wounded it sounds so funny on one level
I get the walls I get why they did it
they're still [__] [__] if
you're out there today watching this
movie you're a piece of shed he was a
deadhead here's a guy who would like
anti-apartheid processors got busted
supposedly for selling 300 hits of
assets Dead shows I mean this is what
he's coming out of so this idea that
these these punks were trying to hurt
people was upsetting so
he didn't have a great opinion of
this um Anonymous whatever it was we
can't let that [__] pass these people
need to either be brought to Justice or
at the very least [__] monitored to
see what else they're going to [__]
do
so I was tasked with literally
infiltrating Anonymous I was to go in
the IRC spend as much time as I could
make as much contacts not to get these
people busted this was not some sort of
law enforcement thing I just want to
know what these people are up to you
know so that's how I get into anonymous
[Music]
there was no founder of anonymous
from late 2007 on there was some degree
of soft power
that in one way or another managed to
Corral phenomenon and did so in ways
that were effective that allowed to
become a decisive Force
sometimes in the history of Nations
there was no reason to expect that would
last without a charter without a
structure
there was no reason to expect this would
go on for too long
it is frankly shocking in retrospect
that it worked for as long as it did my
name is Barrett Brown I'm a journalist
and activist and a Gentleman Adventurer
Anonymous was not founded and I'm not
sure if anybody would have taken
responsibility for it had they actually
found it back in the Fortune Days
the 4chan website the image boards that
have been around since 2004 2005 the
primordial suit from which Anonymous
eventually evolved that was The Crucible
for anonymous so I don't think you can
really understand Anonymous without
understanding 4chan there were message
boards within 4chan it was a forum for
people on the internet to talk freely
and openly about a variety of subjects
then there was a board that was just the
random board slash B where you could
talk about anything that's where it
became a bit more free form and the idea
was that your default handle was
Anonymous that was the name you were
given it was kind of like this hive mind
of the internet and so they started to
do what they called raids which was sort
of like hey let's do like a little field
trip on the Internet it's something fun
and stupid so they did well one of the
famous ones was have a hotel which was
this children's game which they decided
to trade you know have all these
characters with afros I think there were
some like Nazi imagery it was just about
shock value and fun
um obviously offensive fun I've
participated in some of these things
like some of this second life raids
where they would Dawn these bizarre
garish outfits and go around and wave
giant penises like at concerts they're
having a second life another one and a
bomb furry nightclubs I remember
thinking like these sort of the emergent
organization that's going on here this
is a new Dynamic that the internet has
made possible
in a world where there's no more Pioneer
Land there's no more Frontier suddenly
it was all Frontier every direction
I wondered you know what would happen
when these people realize
what power they have
and what greater power they could have
if they were to adopt some shared
ideology some shared enemy even and that
ended up happening
everyone knows that Anonymous existed
depending on how you look at it all the
way back to even late 03. but in reality
that was two people on a website you
know the strangest thing happens you
know in January 08 it becomes this you
know giant movement that the news is
covering and uh that was partially my
fault uh and definitely an accident you
know I look back and I wish I could say
you know I masterminded this amazing
thing on purpose no I I've no idea what
I was doing dude on January 14 2008 up
on 4chan this video is posted of Tom
Cruise being insane Tom Cruise
Scientologist
being a Scientologist
when you drive past an accident it's not
like anyone else as you drive past you
know
you know you know you're the only one
that can really help
and another post comes saying the video
is gone and everyone's like well wait
why did why did that get taken down
that's Tom Cruise being insane it's it's
[__] funny we decided that we're
really good at doxing people we're
really good at getting their information
and hunting people down and uh use some
connections to find the person who had
the video and by we I mean a few of us
who were on IRC uh which is a chat
system we went and found the person who
had uploaded that video and got their
source and we re-uploaded it
it was taken offline in like 30 seconds
Scientology at that point was watching
YouTube for everything going by and like
got it again
and uh that actually pissed us off you
just don't do that you don't take
something off the internet I remember
talking to someone about this and they
equate it to like a like a playground
and somebody took their ball we have
fair use laws uh under the dmca but
YouTube was still caving because they
didn't want to fight a billion dollar
Behemoth like uh you know Scientology
the Church of Scientology had a long
history ever since the internet became a
thing of trying to control it trying to
censor materials from the church that
they consider to be proprietary uh
generally things that are embarrassing
regarding their beliefs so we decided we
were going to troll Scientology by
putting out a press release hello
leaders of Scientology we are Anonymous
over the years we have been watching you
your campaigns of misinformation your
suppression of dissent your litigious
nature it scared of the line between
Goofy and uh awe-inspiring it happens to
successfully
fear towards awe-inspiring Anonymous has
therefore decided that your organization
should be destroyed this is ominous like
we're writing like the internet is
coming for you get ready we shall
proceed to expel you from the internet
and systematically dismantle the Church
of Scientology in its present form
Anonymous promised an army would come
and defeat Scientology would come and
bring just unprecedented chaos it was
about 10 20 at night on the 21st of
January 2008 I don't remember my
birthday half the time I don't know why
this one sticks so well but that we
uploaded this video and I think if I'm
lucky 20 30 people watch this video find
it funny we are Anonymous We Are Legion
we do not forgive we do not forget
expect us
woken up by my girlfriend at the time it
was like 4 30 in the morning she's
calling me maybe five is right around
there and she says turn on CNN and and I
turned on CNN and the videos on CNN and
I'm like what is going on you have
nowhere to hide because we are
everywhere and at that point we're
sitting there with a million views on
the video news reaching out trying to
get a hold of us Scientology paying big
money to Private Eyes trying to find us
and an army kind of in front of us that
are all going by the name Anonymous now
they promise an army they didn't have it
but by virtue of making it clear making
it palpable people wanted this Army that
would emerge from the internet and right
wrongs
and so naively we're like well then
let's plan a global worldwide protest in
every you know major country on the
planet we're going to be those old
school protest types but do it like the
internet does it so make it [__]
we're sending Anonymous outside so they
better remain anonymous so we're going
to need to cover our faces the media
needs something they can show that's the
ominous thing right so we had to give
them a mask
it had to be available so we actually
spent the next about 25 hours calling
comic shops costume shops and literally
every single City we tried to call had
guy Fox masks in stock sitting in back
that no one was buying that they had
discounted because everyone thought
after the V for Vendetta movie that a
million of these would sell and none did
and we're like well great decision made
it's the only mask we can actually use
everyone wants a romantic version of
this story no it was because it was the
only one that was available in every
single town we were going to be in
it was all in US it sort of created this
um mythology of anonymous who is
anonymous what are they they wear these
masks you know and I think that was the
time when Anonymous was really branded
and so having conceived in the Army and
presented the picture of the army came
they happened to be clever enough to
organize all these thousands of people
who saw this video they made
and so the Army was materialized the
Army showed up
this is what the internet would look
like if it went outside there were women
there were people of color every race
there were young and old there was
everyone and we just weren't expecting
that we were really expecting the young
hackers Fortuner guys to all show up in
that to be our little group of 20 that
stood on the corner for an hour and
instead all these other people showed up
and it was great and that's how
anonymous
first became a decisive Force you have a
thing now what do we do with this it had
only been built for fighting Scientology
in reality a Togo was actually just to
screw at them for a week you know again
this being so off the cuff and so
completely accidental every step of it
we didn't expect this to keep going
Scientology protests at that time it was
funny as hell and that's what eventually
sold me on them they really were turned
out to be people that were authentic so
I'm hanging out with these people and
like I said the vast majority you might
have to admit we're good people
at that point in the story there's just
one of those cathartic moments that's
about to happen for really everybody and
that was the release of the collateral
murder video
foreign
[Music]
within weeks of the release of that was
an immediate
thunderstorm of persecution fired off at
Wikileaks Wikileaks picked a fight with
the U.S now the U.S is fighting back in
more ways than one American lawmakers
wanted to see founder Julian Assange
they want to see him tried under the
Espionage Act and the Wikileaks website
has its own trouble this is a new news
here PayPal has announced it has
suspended Wikileaks account costing it a
vital source of funding MasterCard visa
and PayPal agreed to a behind the scenes
U.S embargo against Wikileaks whereby
they all simultaneously more or less
said oh we're not going to process
donations Wikileaks anymore immediately
there is this [__] visceral rage
because websites like the KKK or the
Westboro Baptist Church and have PayPal
donation links on their [__] sites
but then what about what
a publishing company like Wikileaks just
trying to get enough money to pay for
their servers and no are you kidding me
and so Anonymous just left that day the
day the donation portals came down
Anonymous said we're coming for you
supporters of the website Wikileaks
launching a sweeping cyber War this week
that's right it's being called operation
payback or also operation avenge Assange
and it's basically a loose affiliation
of hackers that call themselves
Anonymous this time they're turning
attention to what they consider to be
the enemies of WikiLeaks Visa
MasterCards are the big hits they've had
so far this man calls himself Commander
X and says he's part of anonymous power
of anonymous is is that we have the
ability
to affect
change on the internet their method of
choice a denial of service attack where
hackers overwhelm websites with a huge
volume of requests for information
crashing the sites as Commander X for a
cause that process is is the equivalent
of a virtual City I can best sum up My
Philosophy with the quote that I'm so
famous for and is I admit very [__]
funny uh you only need two things in
this world to be a world-class hacker a
computer and a cool pair of sunglasses
and the computer is optional you have a
say on online
all of a sudden we snap our fingers and
that site is gone anybody can do it you
don't have to be a hacker to take down a
website you know you can download a
program and figure it out in an
afternoon these are all various DDOS
weapons this would be the equivalent of
a rifle and so now our target has been
loaded and as we say an anonymous poo
poo poo and hopefully hundreds if maybe
thousands of people with downwind same
software and all of us fire so it's
really about multiplication this is a
weapon that's designed to be used by an
army and we just kept going it was an
incredible time because that entire 10
days you don't even sleep you have in
essence Julian Assange who has become a
cyber Messiah and hundreds of followers
who are waking up zombie computers
they're soldiers and attacking companies
like Visa Mastercard
and this is the first time you really
begin to hear during those 10 days the
FBI rhetoric was just over the top you
know these are cyber terrorists the
we're going to shut them down and of
course we're all like yeah [__] you yeah
so what it's protest [__] get
used to it
in the midst of that I've been living in
Santa Cruz and I had a cabin up in the
mountains but I used to stay and when I
was in Santa Cruz I didn't pay for a
hotel there's places to sleep Outdoors
Santa Cruz doesn't just have homeless
people
um you have like you're mentally ill and
you're addicted who hover around Santa
Cruz because there's a lot of drugs
there to Surf town
but the vast majority of people that
they label homeless people are actually
just bohemes they're just people
traveling up and down the coast
it's a travel Corridor for backpacking
camper living culture that exists in
California
you will not make it illegal for a man
to fall asleep on the [__] grass and
give them a ticket and even put them in
[__] jail and when that doesn't pass
mustard Court you make a law against
people covering up with a blanket at
night when they're asleep we don't need
to get a blanket law in Santa Cruz I'm
not even [__] you
these homeless people had a protest Camp
going Called Peace camp
we were sleeping on the courthouse steps
who are sleeping in protest we're
sleeping literally with a sign next to
us that said I am protesting the Sleep
law that's why I'm sleeping here
there's people sleeping all over this
[__] Courthouse what's going on here
it's peace camp 2010.
We're Stars man peace Camp 2010 they
can't get enough of us we got the media
Darlings I imagine that's right the
Santa Cruz County Courthouse where
homeless activists have been protesting
city ordinances for more than a month
we have a squad of shares on hand
the Santa Cruz Police Department
despised all of us professional
protesters let's go find you're sleeping
here illegally
for you
who are not guilty because
an attention began to grow in Santa Cruz
very very big time
you're going to arrest us
and I'd been arrested hey Chris you have
a warrant out for your arrest your hands
behind your back
nobody had any clue that this scraggly
guy with a long red beard and everything
is like one of the most notorious
hackers online with a name Commander X
I uh decided that I would harness my new
friends that I was garnering in the
anonymous Collective
and I said I got a plan I said I think I
want to take down the County website
I said but I want to be super cool about
it because I'm here in this [__] town
so what I'd like to do is do a really
ethical hacking style let's do it at on
a Sunday at noon
for 30 minutes and we'll pre-announce it
we'll tell them the specific time it is
going to be down to the you know
the public will know that you just just
wait you know and it will come back
I just went off and did it I sat in a
[__] coffee house and I'm churning
out these attacks I'm deploying cyber
weapons that our crew built just to
deedaw [__]
two detectives from Santa Cruz shares
walked in and gave everybody a good
[__] look over and that's when I
started packing up to get the [__] out
of there oh my God my [__] hot is
coming out of my chest a sweat pouring
off me I got my pack of my back my
laptop over my shoulder and I just
[__] scoot left and walk normal as
you can
but anyway I make my way to the library
put out the press release from the
library
and then the next morning I'd get up and
the headline is on the Santa Cruz paper
I mean in big black letters
Santa Cruz Cyber attack
and I knew I knew I just knew it was
epic and I knew that my life would never
be the same again
and the other thing I also knew was that
Anonymous was the most powerful force
ever to be created in humanity so far
and that no doubt they were [__]
coming for us and coming for us with
guns drawn literally
cyber is the battlefield of the future
and most of these attackers are going
after whatever the hell they can
in order to show you what they can do
and that is very hard very frankly to
defend against
I'm uh Leon Panetta former director of
the CIA former Secretary of Defense and
now chairman of The Panetta Institute
for Public Policy power can be very
infatuating
when you know you have power and you can
exercise that power
and I think in many ways that's what
happened with a group like Anonymous and
other hacking groups that suddenly
realized
they had their hands on a very powerful
weapon and they weren't quite sure
and I think they still remain not quite
sure about just exactly
what it means you know for something
like the CIA and for other intelligence
agencies at least you know
the devil that you're after
but when it comes to anonymous hackers
it was much more difficult to try to
figure out what are they after what
damage could they do are these just a
bunch of people you know playing 21st
century hacking games
or are these people
that have a motivation that could be
very dangerous to our security I was
[__] Batman
and I had powers by then I was like
gearing up I'm geeking up I'm starting
to [__] bust some [__] I'm starting
to [__] have some fun with this
because I was working very hard by that
point I was putting in 10 12 15 hour
days to this movement of anonymous I was
participating to the fullest extent that
I could do and not die
Commander X is who he is and you know we
all know we've all seen his his version
of reality but um he didn't come into my
Orbit until people started talking to me
about the fact that X said he talked to
you on IRC and I'm like who he just kind
of showed up as a guy who was putting up
websites under the Anon name and you'd
look at it and the website looked like
it was built in 1993 like one of the
first drafts of a website ever that a
guy who was openly telling us he was
homeless was building so like he didn't
want to just outright say uh what the
[__] guy you wanted to say okay guys
trying with very limited resources he
would be you know you're doing his thing
and obviously he was doing ddosing he
was hitting targets he was I didn't
think he was doing too much harm and I
was always kind to him because
surprisingly enough I am actually lately
a kind person by default that I just
said that nice thing and sometimes like
it's sarcastic like go forth continue
Commander as I understand his story he
was the kind of hippie protester who
showed up and you know was holding signs
anti-war and all that you know and that
was none of us to speak the honest truth
like I'm the 19 year old driving a car
who sees a puddle and a bunch of people
at a bus stop and hits the puddle as
fast as he can that's me at 19. I'm I'm
not the good guy so from the very
beginning there was definitely a clash
of just personalities because he came at
it from a completely different way we
sort of
were thrust into being activists very
accidentally and that was just who he
thought he was
I did not have all access at that point
to Anonymous I was you know definitely
very strong and very powerful person and
had to respect even though people like
Barrett Brown and Greg house and stuff
like that and I remember clearly going
to Barrett Brown and asking him what do
you think we should do next I think he
responded with just one word keep an eye
on the Middle East
greater ex and I did not sit there and
plan the Advent of opt Tunisia in the
fusion Revolution
Revolution began when a fruit vendor in
Tunis the capital
set himself on fire in protest of the
local corrupt police having taken away
his assets failure to pay abroad
that is what sparks the initial
conflagration that's what started the
street uprisings the rage it provided
an enzyme orchids are a catalyst right
I'm a group of chemistry or much else
fight a catalyst a center of attention
for those in the country who are aware
of it to Rally around Tunisia is is one
of those interesting ones where they
invited us in we didn't even come and
talk to them they came and talked to us
you know at first we all didn't think we
could help I mean honestly strange
enough mandarex was the first one on
that channel saying no we can absolutely
do this and we all thought he was
[__] insane I mean like who who the
hell are we this is a dictator of an
African nation some Tunisian hackers
came to us an enormous and in fact they
were more or less handed off to me
because nobody knew quite what to do
with them but they claimed to have some
rather extraordinary access but needed
some assistance
um it's a small country with a small
infrastructure and we have the usernames
and passwords to everything
you name it the water supply like the
radio stations the servers that the
president's email is on you don't have
to hack anything we just have the
passwords here you go
so we were able to prove that these
people were receiving just enormous
bribes living like Gods while Tunisia
drowned in poverty and so now these
people are are really just [__]
furious is this right who are the people
who are planning on going on the streets
are they are they our people you know
are are we helping some extremists who
are going to make it worse so we did a
lot of work with these guys and we did
uh honestly like days of research into
who the president was Ben Ali who he was
you know the dictator uh you know turns
out the people who are going the streets
were really the people and uh they
needed to overthrow this this dictator
to the extent there is right and wrong
and that one can point to a large group
of people and say that one is mostly
right that one is mostly wrong there was
never any question that we were right
and that if if this was to escalate
further it would be a terrible thing for
living involved but I would personally
uh be enthusiastic about that
[Applause]
I mean you look at it and you think what
could hackers do but you'd be surprised
at how important it is to keep
communication from City to City
we built this list of all the
Technologies they would block and we
kind of estimated what order they would
try and block them in like easiest
they're going to just get Twitter and
Facebook turned off in the country right
so we put proxies up and fed them to all
the people in the major cities as as
soon as the these start working access
them this way
get activated satellite phones to some
of the people in these towers yes we can
let's do the best
it keeps going from there to like seven
layers of communication so when the
internet goes down then when the cell
phones go down we can keep handing them
a new way to keep in contact
[Music]
is all unraveling in hours and days it's
great next speed
I thought as we talked about earlier in
the apartheid movement for 10 [__]
years
it took 10 days during the dictator
attitude
[Music]
after Tunisia we're starting to help the
Egyptians with the same tools because
now we've kind of got a tool kit
we're really beginning to Define skill
sets that specifically apply to these
Street revolutions
one of the things we had done there was
we knew the internet was going to get
cut pretty easily so our preparedness
for that was we had gotten dial up isps
old school 90s level modems mailed into
Egypt so if the internet got completely
cut but the phones were still working
they could dial into the internet
they turn the internet back on in Egypt
three times
so the Egyptians were using internet to
organize what would become the Arab
Spring
oh my God we are having geopolitical
impact
we're saying who's going to [__] rule
in this world and who isn't
none of these were our protests when you
look at any of the stuff we did during
the Arab Spring none of them were our
ideas this is a revolution for the
sincere people of this country they're
the ones that want to make the change
they're the ones that will make the
change
true heroes of this country people
showed up asked for our help it turned
out it was things we could do so we did
it and then I went back to building uh
some plumber's website the next day
I mean I think we came out of the area
of spring pretty convinced we were all
[__] gods Commander X is is
definitely a victim of his own ego at
this point
was commander X on the ground in in uh
the square and Tunis in the capital uh
getting shot at
no there were people on the ground
risking their lives
they could have possibly done this
without us
we could not have done it without them
by the time the Tunisian Revolution was
over by the time Egypt had started the
FBI rated 40 U.S households on a single
day in late January 2011 over these DDOS
attacks slowed down MasterCards
corporate website
and visas
and paypals for a couple seconds armed
rates families being held at gunpoint in
some cases they were guided for us this
is like [__]
War dozens of FBI agents targeted
alleged members of the loose knit
hacking group armed with search warrants
agents hit six homes in New York along
with locations across the country CC
hard drives and computer accessories
it's all the same moment literally the
same [__] moment that's how they do
this [__] so that we can't get on like
IRC and say hey dudes they're coming
[__] wipe your drives and run and
that's so that's what they did except
there's only got 39 of them because one
[Music]
was Batman
the reaction that they had was so need
here to our attacks on PayPal Mastercard
and Visa visa.com went offline for a few
minutes did that affect anyone's ability
to buy anything or give anyone's info
away no it didn't nothing their
marketing piece where you could download
a brochure was offline for a few minutes
somehow 50 million dollars and damn it
no dude no when have you as someone who
has a Visa card ever gone to visa.com it
didn't affect anyone
uh and it was down for five minutes but
they tried to get people you know to go
to prison for it MasterCards website was
offline for a couple hours but again
that was their fault their [__] was
really badly built
um but again
very clearly nobody uses those sites to
do their transactions those sites are
advertising
you know what does it take to get a case
indicted these days
a couple million Bitcoin and extortions
and things like that
whereas you know whether to take a case
to get indicted in 2010
the low orbit ion cannon
[Music]
by Nature it's a joke like the thing
says pew pew on it it debates by Nature
it's a joke and you know
a joke will get you prison in 2010. my
name is Jay Lederman I'm a criminal
defense attorney
I do a lot of Underdog work I do a lot
of
um stuff that people won't touch because
they're worried it's it too high or too
clandestine a level that men in you know
black Escalades are going to pull up and
what have you and that [__] doesn't
happen that that's come on don't tell
them that though because then I I miss
out on all my fun
I sent out a series of tweets that I
would uh represent some righteous
activists busted in my foot meaning
California so in our general mailbox the
next day there was a message from them
and said I'm Commander ax and you know I
am the commander X not just Commander X
I am V Commander X and
um you thought they were looking for him
for the potential Santa Cruz DDOS
consider that unauthorized access any
thought that things were going down very
quickly we're going to be going down
very quickly for him
I was in Mountain View California
and I had known that they had pretty
much tracked me to Mountain View I was
seeing the Crown Vics around I saw the
FBI agents in the library when I was
surfing on the internet near Ludo had me
surrounded by at least a dozen agents
at all times
they must have really really feared me
at that at that point to deploy a dozen
agents rather than just walk up and
[__] arrest me
I'm going back and forth with X you know
we had the meeting spot arranged at that
point I'm still using like some sort of
commercial based email
I'm still new and he was using some
encrypted form of email for some reason
he said to me the last email he said to
me was like Jay I'll see you at uh 10
o'clock at the such and such Coffee
House
and I I said why on Earth did you say
that he had told me the name of the
place weeks before I had it I had it
written down I knew where I was going
there's a guy in Bermuda shorts and that
stupid Hawaiian shirt that they always
make FBI agents where thinking that
somehow [__] stealthy and he's
staring right [__] at me as I'm
walking down the street so I'm like okay
so it's a game right so I'll play the
game I go to the coffee house another
FBI agent comes in sits down takes my
[__] picture with his cell phone and
I was like okay let's see if you know
about the secret [__] passageway out
of this [__] coffee house because I
did
down the [__] stairs I went out the
[__] back door
Nadia the [__] the Fib from hell she
was screaming because she [__] saw me
bolting down this alley and couldn't get
out of traffic in time to come after me
ended up coming up the [__] sidewalk
with pedestrians literally weeping Out
of This Woman's way as he dries up the
[__] sidewalk
and I was just sat down in a bus stop I
wet a cigarette
and an FBI agent who I've come to call a
cyber crime guy get out of the van
calmed Nadia the fifth down meter put
her gun away
and just calmly sat there with me and
waited while I finished my cigarette he
asked me my name and I said dude if you
don't know who you're about to arrest
you're not doing the job right right
then Jay Lederman drove by I was looking
for parking and I got a call from my
office
that Christopher Doyle was off
yeah I called back the number and it was
an FBI agent they were like yeah hold on
he wants to talk to you
they got him an hour before I got there
at the place we had arranged to meet
I don't know what their methods are who
knows if they had like some camera
planted in the little whatever tree X
was like you know sleeping under you
know looking at his computer when he's
typing it you know I can't prove that it
was on my end but it sure appears that
the FBI violated a turn client privilege
by having my emails monitored and were
able to pick him up an hour before I
arrived at the meeting
[Music]
at that point I went through a couple of
days of Court hearings to determine
exactly what the [__] they were going to
do with me
they were alleging sixty two hundred
dollars in Damages they did what they
could to make sure it was over five
thousand dollars because that's what
they were told by the United States
attorney's office how do I know that
even though I don't know that because
that's what every United States
attorney's office tells everyone about
it they say listen you got to get this
over five thousand dollars or this is a
misdemeanor this is just some guy in a
library like click and enter on his
computer come on man it's like what's
this worth and and then that's what
ultimately happened with PayPal it was
you know be good for 18 months and and
we'll dismiss all of these of course he
could have gotten 15 years
so I was released on bail
it's a mistake tactically on their part
you had me
and you let me go and so of course I
went back to the [__] War
I'd like to state to the public record
that this press conference is being held
against the advice of my Wiggles house X
is good at giving attorneys ulcers
me I I'm also proof I I work fine this
document alleges
that I in the notorious hacker activist
known to the world as Commander X
I am Commander X
well I don't know you try to tell him to
shut up see how that works the
indictment further alleges that I am in
association with the global internet
Freedom Movement known as anonymous
and I say yes
I am immensely proud
humbled to the Core
to be a part of the idea called
Anonymous he does have the right to
remain silent he chooses not to exercise
it you know I am a homeless guy
scary smoke
and despite the best efforts of the city
the county
and now the federal governments
I will not be silenced the FBI is now in
possession of three of my computers two
[__] cell phones and God knows how
many [__] external tribes
they taking all my electronics they've
forbidden me from using Electronics well
how am I going to handle this I can't go
back to hacking but I want to keep
fighting and keep [__] with him and
it dawned on me what I was going to do
I'm going to say goodbye and I'm not
coming back
and I began my run to the Canadian
border
as far as I knew I think he was like
sort of the first fugitive out of this
whole movement
I never really believed that he was in
Canada
because it seemed to
obvious you know it's like hiding in
plain sight Green in Canada like I
really didn't think he had gone to
Canada
and sure as heck he went to Canada
if you want to call me a terrorist I've
got no problem with that
but I would ask you who is it that's
terrified and if it's the bad guys that
are terrified
[Music]
um I'm really super okay with that
the media for some reason loved talking
to and about Commander x i i
for the life of me never got it but I
also didn't think I had to like the
things he was saying in the media well
sometimes they were crazy most of the
times they were just our talking points
I went to go see him up in Montreal
whenever you heard interviews with
somebody an anonymous they treated it
like you know you were just you were
some like troll that had run out of a
cave and you're all pixelated and all of
that but like here was a guy who kind of
looks like an older hippie guy and that
put a face on something that had been
faceless to a lot of people but I think
it was in that moment too when he really
became even more ostracized within the
subculture of anonymous because the one
thing you weren't supposed to do was to
distinguish yourself really as an
individual and put a face on something
that's faceless a lot of accusations
have been levied at him about what
literally is referred to as Fame horn
and they're not entirely wrong I mean he
obviously wanted it he literally named
himself Commander his own version of the
story you know very much says that he
came in and was you know helping to make
things better and um
there were certainly people who just
felt that Commander X didn't deserve to
have a feature in the New Yorker about
him it was that line in the New Yorker
but I forgot who said it was like you
know I really got sick of commandorex we
started comparing himself to Batman
that is a line that if it is said about
you if it is written about if it is
something everyone agrees with if it
could be uttered in in truth uh should
be enough but let me go further it's an
albatross he was an anchor an anchor on
all of our necks he would claim that
like actions are being taken that
weren't being taken uh at levels that
just we weren't working at at that time
his Alias is Commander X and in some
recent interviews he's made some
startling claims he says that Anonymous
may very well be the most powerful
organization on Earth that the group of
50 000 members worldwide have access to
every classified database in the US
government people would then be like why
did he say that I mean that just sounds
stupid like we could bring small
children in here like we could tell them
oh we have access to every classified
data and like a five or six year old but
suddenly would work that out and be like
well how do you know first of all that
you have all of them and second of all
uh you know why would you say that out
loud if you really did wouldn't that be
best of security breach talk a little
bit more about that
but I have nothing more to say what do
you want to know it was getting to
people because he was also making the
message look bad like he says this
that's obviously insane then another
Anon says something that's obviously
true but they're all insane several
weeks ago I began research and
experimentation on the development of a
software program and kit that when
downloaded installed would allow the
user to conduct true time travel
essentially turning their home computer
into a time machine this is literally a
[__] email hero 2009. I was taking a
break from reading up on the theory
behind Sonic time travel and I was
sitting under a tree that's a sitting on
our tree that's obnoxious I was
wondering idly if I would ever crack the
theory of time travel
how could you even wonder that at that
moment myself from approximately 25
years in the future came strolling down
High Street the me from the future less
than 10 feet away turned and actually
smirked at me
I guess my time travel software kit
works that's Commander X that guy was
was getting was was
among those people who when I was not
able to formulate the message bet in the
background or the foreground with the
press it was him and it was increasingly
him and then when I went to prison
very much him
[Music]
the FBI rated me on March 6 2012. uh
rated my Apartments first thought I
wasn't there
which was by Design
then rid of my mom's house and uh took
about Electronics computers phones files
like they had taken files and papers
from my place and then six months later
after I had learned
I've been told by the prosecutor that
they were going to be charging my mom as
well which is a very common progress
among the FBI charging someone's female
loved ones to get them to cooperate and
knowing uh myself that I would never
cooperate with the FBI
I've made several videos laying all this
out hi I'm bear brown again this is part
three of a three-part series on why man
with the FBI
I've got a case of the giggles
um my mom has not been involved in any
of this at all it's not it's not do not
know about the tip I received previous
day didn't know I was over there I come
over there a lot I didn't know why I
brought you know laptops over you know
the notice didn't pay attention I also
threatened to shoot anybody a more FBI
agents in my house
they know that I'm armed and I come from
a military family but I was taught to
shoot by a Vietnam vet and by my father
a master hunter and I will shoot all of
them and kill them
it was pretty obvious I was going to be
dead before I was 40 or so so I wouldn't
mind going out with two FBI sidearms and
[__] Egyptian pharaoh and so I was
ready
[Music]
done
oh it's better getting [__] rated by
the FBI yes
a few months later I was uh charged this
time with 11 counts of aggravated
identity theft
the charges in this case justify it
involved me copying and pasting a link
from an anonymous IRC chat room then a
month later after that after those
charges I was charged once more for
profession of Justice just like my mom
was for hiding laptops in her kitchen
cabinet so
long story short I went to prison
if America is supposed to be the Bastion
of Liberty around the world how do I
even end up here in Mexico how does [__]
like this even happen
the Computer Fraud and Abuse Act is one
of the worst punished statutes out there
in that the amount of time you can get
in relation to the harm caused is
astounding
yeah okay I'm criminal what I face now
is 12 years
in prison
this is hanging over his head as does an
absconding charge now so now on top of
the 12 is added another seven
we're now talking about 19 years and I'd
in prison do not have that long to live
so it's a life sentence
and for me that's still I understand
I actually first went to Toronto because
of the world premiere of a documentary
called We Are Legion
introduce yourself
all right I first met X at a um at an
occupy protest in in Oakland at the
height of the Occupy Movement and at
that point he was homeless he was uh he
was clearly living on the streets he was
attracted to the movement because of uh
its activist potential I have stood upon
the Mountaintop known as Anonymous and
looked down on a world inflamed wood
Revolution I saw him again when he was
homeless in Toronto and he was you know
Toronto is not an easy place to be
homeless and uh you know he wasn't doing
well he wasn't doing well no country
should be allowed to stifle with
Ascension a point where people are
committing suicide and people would
fleeing their own country never to
return I mean think about the decision I
made of Never Going Home
something about the city
made me feel like it would be a very
awesome place for me to take a bit of a
break
and maybe blend in you know I'll settle
here seems all right
and so I met Ian Thornton when he was
just walking down the street
as a recently turned Storyteller this
was Goldust I mean it wasn't there was
no master plan to do anything with it
but viscerally this is the sort of thing
that a Storyteller dreams of Truth
being weirder Than Fiction this had to
be investigated
almost every person who I've ever
revealed myself to while I was on the
run all said the same thing why did you
tell me
why would you do something that stupid
and Ian too asked me why would you do
that and simply because I needed help
so this for several years
was the bedroom of Commander X
and quite uncannily someone has been
using it
as a bedroom
he slept with his laptop underneath his
head he would wrap it in bubble wrap
particularly during the winter make it
watertight and then if he were Disturbed
during the night at least his laptop was
under his head and he'd get up every
morning he'd go to the to the coffee
shop and that's where he'd start his
electronic warfare and mischief and
intrigue he helped me write the Books
because I didn't have an agent I didn't
have a lawyer I didn't have a publisher
you know he gave me safe houses whenever
I needed them hotel rooms airbnbs he had
a college out by the lake he knew what
my goals were which was to find Asylum
we went through some incredible
experiences where we really thought I
was going to Iceland for a minute
and then it didn't pan out we thought
for a moment quite seriously I might be
going to Russia
and that didn't piano
thank you
very much everybody
and then Trump got elected sorry to keep
you awaiting complicated business Donald
Trump had already made himself a a rabid
enemy of the Mexican people in the
Mexican Government we will build a great
wall along the southern border
and Mexico will pay for the wall
you can use my voice we will never pay
for that [__] wall Trump had really
ratcheted up the the the the tension
between the two countries and when
you're looking for Asylum this is what
you're looking for it's a political hack
you're essentially looking to pit two
nation states against each other
for the sole purpose of creating a tiny
bubble of freedom for yourself so Mexico
is looking really in play here the big
problem of course is geography right
I've got to go back into the United
States of America and do I really want
to go back from being a political
dissident in Exile in Canada to being a
fugitive
both boots Underground
and so I produced a 30 page PDF and
called Ian to the coffee house I said so
what do you think and he's like you're
not going to actually do this right
and I was like
yeah I think I'm going to do it
I should want to help
and so that was born operation Golden
Eagle Golden Eagle for those not maybe
up to speed is the national bird of
Mexico they made a nice code name I
secretly contacted Barrett round and I
said do you want to come with me dude
you want to get out when I won't go to
Mexico with you when I'm you know to
leave a a country that I have uh
increasingly come to the spies it means
I don't like you and don't think much of
your planning ability and his decision
was no how many times you have to flee
the country I just want to do it once
foreign
[Music]
Golden Eagle is by far the weirdest
human endeavor
probably in human history so far it was
the most elaborate
thoughtful Anonymous operation that I
have ever been a part of
100 kilometers to Altoona begins
now this is a Southeastern Manitoba
Canada we knew it was hunting season in
Manitoba we knew if I was going to go
through wood to Manitoba I might get
shot at and I did one has to [__]
wonder how a hacker from Cambridge ends
up in a place like this
and out of Altoona I will break back
into my own country
and guess what this is our first camp in
the United States of America
because that folks
that's North Dakota
I'm now by my own choice
a full-on Futures Wanted Dead or Alive
how do you like them Atlas
of actually taking a cab right out of 10
dinner
straight to Grand Forks
the Grand Forks of catching a greyhound
all the way to El Paso all the way to
what we call in this operation the exit
node which is El Paso that's El Paso is
the city that all staged my exit out of
America if something's going to go wrong
it's going to go wrong like he's 15
co-opters or some cop jacked me up way
the [__] out here because I can't
explain what the [__] I'm doing out here
bullet cases
[Music]
people are out here shooting
but if I don't make it
or if I'm killed by Bandits
or if I'm captured by the United States
authorities in the last one and a half
kilometers to the Border
I want you to know I did my best but
hopefully I make it
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
I had this laptop when he switched for a
new one a more lightweight one for his
trip he wanted to be far more
streamlined and and this was the stuff
that he left
oh geez look at this this is World War
One stuff
[Music]
when I hooked him at the Greyhound
station in September 2017. I didn't
think I was going to see him ever again
but I will be surprising him in Mexico
City on Guy Fawkes Day
[Music]
people in the anonymous Collective were
born to watch my Twitter very carefully
and so I I began to tease hey guys watch
me on November 5th thank you
because I didn't want to just announce
I'm going to be at the monument ahead of
time
I'm going to do something really cool
guys keep an eye out
I have hundreds and hundreds of
journalists to follow my Twitter account
just for that reason
well we're on our way to the million
Mass March in Mexico City
just to remind the people in power that
we're still here we're still Legion and
we're still everywhere and we never
forgive we never forget
[Applause]
since 2013 actually we've been doing
million Mass marches
it galvanizes
thinks they associate with anonymous
all in one day
so to celebrate how much we've grown
over the last year meet other anons
and if that's kind of cathartic that's a
pretty big thing for an Anon because we
don't get to meet each other very often
there's a lot going on here in Latin
America there's a lot of tension there
are people in the streets of Chile
Ecuador Bolivia Venezuela
they are Marching against their
government and all of those protests in
Latin America have at least the
potential of overthrowing their their
government so if the culture is
generally speaking in a revolutionary
mood that's a really big sign that today
could be good and even bigger than
normal I would not be at all even
marginally surprised to see two thousand
um could be even bigger
foreign
thank you
dude how do I keep ending up and all
these icons of Revolution like I
literally live like a block away with a
rooftop view of D4 where the entire
Mexican Revolution began it's like a
[__] Shrine and now
completely with no input of my own here
I am at the monument that revolutional I
mean come on dude
[Music]
today is a million mask March Anonymous
Million last March and Anonymous has
always support Julian so uh although all
over the world uh Julian supporters
decide to show up on this day on
November 5th and wear a Julian mask
instead of anonymous mask
[Music]
um
no pressure
everybody
talk to my people
[Music]
all right guys this is Commander X live
like a million mask March you know we're
fuel right now that's true Maybe by
other standards of other million mask
marches but that can change in a
heartbeat if you are
somewhere in Mexico City right now and
you happen to be listening to the stream
then you know get your [__] down here
we're not going anywhere and if you
can't then just get busy and start
tweeting streams other people's streams
as well as my own make it go everywhere
make everything go everywhere about
million Master it's really make
ourselves known this year
[Music]
your life is completely used to this
mine wasn't
so when we started to live our adventure
I was doing stuff that was completely
foreign to me and was scary
and the crescendo was when
you cut your way into into Mexico
you know I started out with a great idea
and then it was sort of like flying at a
hundred miles an hour off a cliff in
Juarez
[Music]
I left Juarez thinking this was [__]
up [__] I was screwed and I'm gonna end
up living in a Hut in the desert in
[__] Mexico eating cactuses for the
rest of my life honest to God I thought
I had it was completely [__]
there was a point in time where I gave
up hope and quit even trying and that's
when I went and got Xander
okay
look at you
three months old
[Music]
that was the moment when I was gonna
just leave this Mortal spear or Mortal
coil as they say
this is Xander's first Christmas on
planet Earth
[Music]
oh
what and the size of that [__] phone
bloody
I decided to give it one more fight with
like literally the last bit of
me left it's a weird thing and I mean
thank God it turned around I guess right
and I didn't cash out I guess really you
kind of got to thank my dog for that I
mean really how weird is it the world
might end up getting saved by a [__]
dog
[Music]
I'm here going to watch her now you know
having spent a couple years almost
exactly here in Mexico
you know I've moved around a lot I've
met people I've I've generally try to
build a network of friends to help me do
the same right same size
is this Grande or just I like the color
too I take that one yeah yeah
and dust comes into a play people like
Vic
well I was just walking in the streets
and then I saw this american guy who's
standing
all lost to know where to go I just saw
him like looking one way in the other
and he saw us and hey guys do you speak
English yeah hey where can I go to a
coffee shop and I'm like okay let me let
me take you there especially because of
the streets here
so we started walking we started we
started talking and then he kind of
asked some questions to see if I kind of
knew a little bit about well Anonymous
and I'm like oh yeah I'm familiar with
it
and if we talk a little bit more and he
said that he was one of the founders of
anonymous and when I whenever I got back
home I searched online I was like oh
[__] it's truly him I don't think and I
was like damn now I search him online I
mean and I got all paranoid right so he
sent me an email and he was oh I slept
in a dumpster is my my birthday like it
was the worst birthday of my life so
well I was like what am I gonna do maybe
you can stay there for a couple of
months and two things get I don't know
good again
yeah I mean he became a really good
friend usually because kind of nobody
likes him
I like broken things
[Music]
foreign
books to make grocery money there it is
all right
I heard a [__] stampeding Turtles
we're off
most of my friends were not actually
aware of any of this and we just The
Eccentric American who lives in
Guanajuato nobody knew anything about me
and so I felt that it was incumbent upon
me to let them know that hey actually
I gotta get the secret
and I mean I tried to put myself in
their shoes for a moment and think wow
what if I found out that Vic was like
freaking Batman
you know that's the kind of level of
revelation this is you know you got a
really serious secret life here that
nobody knew about it
necesita
my goal is to confront the Mexican
Government
surrender to their Authority and made my
case for Asylum because in this country
I have the right to do so
as as a as an underground as a dissident
of whipped amongst you
and I've had a very normal life I mean
I've been so [__] happier
and
that that normalcy is just a taste of
what I hope that I can have if the
government of Mexico will do the right
thing
they will let me stay here in this
country in your country
and if fate will allow me to remain in
this city that's what I want to do for
the rest of my life
is Commander X on the run for a good
reason
um I I honestly do not know if Commander
X is on the run for any good reason I
don't know that he represents a serious
threat to to law enforcement now I mean
if you if you were to take the top 1000
or 2 000 biggest threats to our cyber
security in the United States my guess
is Commander X isn't anywhere near that
list
I I've done several cases up in um San
Francisco
and the person who was you know
Prosecuting his case initially is the
head of the unit now and it's been a
couple years but I mean the last time I
talked to him he's like you know say
hello Mr doyon we you know we'll see him
at some point and we'll get ourselves
reacquainted
I would have no doubt that he would be a
prize trophy on some U.S attorney's wall
there is so much that is inexcusable
that what happens to all of us starting
with that incident with the 40 U.S rates
by the FBI 40 homes rated by armed FBI
agents over a a incident that slowed
down a corporate website for a few
seconds
there are a lot of people especially a
lot of media who have said that you know
those arrests really led to a an end of
anonymous and uh very much a Slowdown of
hacktivism but
what it more did was drive it a little
more underground here in the U.S and
cause people to realize that they needed
to uh actually you know be anonymous a
little better
[Music]
I would remind
any cognizant human being who considers
himself a citizen of a democracy doesn't
mind for consent
when someone like me is targeted or
someone else at whistleblowers targeted
we are not the ultimate Target the
public is the ultimate Target it wasn't
a [__] with me
it was to prevent you from being able to
act as a citizenry which no one in this
community intelligence Community the doj
FBI no one considers you and your
informed consents to be a to be a proper
thing
if you don't understand that that's a
subject matter here you are not a
citizen
you're part of the problem
you know I I I've heard all the
arguments uh and and I I understand this
is about Freedom of Information
Etc
but the reality is that we're also
dealing with something that could be
very dangerous
for example when the Russians you know
use cyber to come after our election
systems in 2016.
[Music]
did they cross a line
because that was a bold attack
we don't know the answer to that and at
some point I think we need to have that
dialogue
about what are some of the rules of the
game here when it comes to cyber because
if we just sit back and say to hell with
that this is we should let everybody do
their own thing
at some point we're going to pay a hell
of a price
hopefully you guys can see uh the stream
okay I'll turn it back around for me
thank you for tuning in this morning
hopefully like I said everything will
turn out okay I have my legal paperwork
with me
[Music]
here I am cameras in tow and everything
requesting political Asylum and
emergency Refugee status
I've always known that this moment would
come but I also didn't want to [__] it
up
so I wanted to make sure that the market
was perfect and I believe that we're in
that moment
you know it's the end of a long [__]
run 10 [__] years and not at all sure
that I would ever make it to this to
this moment
I bought these boots just for the
journey the day I left Toronto to come
here to Mexico I bought these boots
those boots that traveled ten thousand
kilometers ten thousand kilometers
[Music]
you make the decision then yeah of
course you
accept the consequences and the
consequences of this decision is I would
most likely never go home except perhaps
in a box
[Music]
my goal originally was to keep fighting
and not get caught I'm still fighting
and I'm not caught
and I'm this close to Victory
and this time in a very permanent final
way you're not [__] gonna drag me
back and change
end of conversation
I'm going to get [__] Asylum
are you gonna do what are you what is
the purpose of your visit
and now being 99 sure that we got our
ducks in a row
and the things are in place that need to
be in place and I will be I believe
shortly surrendering myself to the
authority and and in the sanctuary
and the safety of the Mexican Government
I'm happy to report that today the
government of Mexico did the right thing
officials of the inm have accepted my
petition material for political Asylum
and have granted me emergency Refugee
status
I am the first information activist in
history to receive political asylum in a
foreign country for protest actions
taken under the flag of anonymous
one of the reasons that I stuck with
this process to The Bitter End despite
my not really having to was my fervent
hope that I will not be the last you
know the way he talks about it it's
almost like you're talking with a
Vietnam veteran who's talking about his
brothers in arms I mean he really
feels it and and gets emotional
the reality is too is that Anonymous and
ex all these people like they've left a
trail online if you dig hard enough you
can find it and Commander X will be
remembered as one of these iconic
figures divisive figures whether you
believe him or not
[Music]
yeah
yeah well now that he's uh
almost Mexican but not speaking Spanish
it's gonna be very hard for him
Hi how are you
oh you have English
oh you have more than I am Spanish one
burrito Perfecto thank you so much this
is gonna be a lot of fun like watching
him like getting a job being stable
having a routine like work I think it's
gonna be
even harder than getting the residency
yeah yeah look at this oh I've always
sort of concerned for him and about him
could I sense there are better days
ahead for him he's he's now a Bonafide
or he feels like a bona fide a human
being again he has a piece of paper from
a government with his picture on it and
even for an anarchist and a Maverick and
a rebel such as he that seems to make
him feel somewhat whole again
as for him and his his activism there
who knows
I don't know like his personality it's
kind of like a big a big [__] the system
a little big I don't want to be part of
this so he's going to find a way he's
always gonna find a way like to push the
boundaries of the system and I think
that's cool one last shot of this
beautiful Square here is a beautiful
Church
and this incredible historic square of
San Miguel de Allende the city where I
won my freedom here in Mexico
thank you guys I'm going to tune out now
thank you guys for watching and I'll see
you all later tonight on Anonymous
fights back look for that on Twitter
I'll be on expect me
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]